,
SMUGNESS, AND GROUPTHINK.
SEAN HANNITY IS UP NEXT.
>> Sean: HAY, TUCKER,
THANK YOU AND WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
BREAK INTO NIGHT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT IS NOW AT THIS HOUR
ISSUING A SECURITY ALERT TELLING
ALL AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN TO
IMMEDIATELY LEAVE THE GATES
SURROUNDING GARSIDE
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT AS THE
SITUATION NOW IN AFGHANISTAN
REMAINS DIRE.
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS AND OUR
ALLIES ARE TRAPPED BEHIND ENEMY
LINES, THE SITUATION IS
DETERIORATING BY THE HOUR.
>> THE TALIBAN WHETHER WE LIKE
IT OR NOT IS IN CONTROL, LARGELY
IN CONTROL OF THE COUNTRY.
CERTAINLY IN CONTROL OF THE CITY
OF KABUL.
>> THEY ARE FIGHTING THEIR
REALITY OF THE TALIBAN.
>> ENCOURAGING THE PRESIDENT TO
STAY ON, BUT HE HAS A WAY OF THE
EQUITIES OF THE DANGER VERSUS
THE ADVANTAGE AND I TRUST HIS
JUDGMENT.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TELLING THE
AMERICANS, MAY BE THEY ARE NOT
IN KABUL BUT THEY ARE SOMEWHERE
IN AFGHANISTAN, HOW WILL THEY
GET OUT?
>> I'M IN CONTACT WITH MY
FRIENDS AND FAMILY AND EVERYONE
SAYS THAT WE DO NOT KNOW
WHERE --
>> WE ARE ON THE CONSTANT
PRECIPICE OF HAVING THE MOST
MASSIVE HOSTAGE SITUATION IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
IT'S GOING TO MAKE TEHRAN LOOK
LIKE A SLEEPOVER.
>> HOW MANY ARE ON THE
WATCH LIST THAT HAVE BEEN
SCREENED OR FOUND IN ANY OF THE
SCREENING POINTS IN EITHER --
OR THE U.S.?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> IF YOU GO TO AFGHANISTAN AND
ENDING THE WAR BETWEEN U.S.,
IRAQ, AND ISLAM, YOU ARE A FOOL.
>> THE AMERICANS BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
KT 11.
>> Sean: AMERICANS HELD
HOSTAGE BEHIND ENEMY LINES DAY
11, AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
PROMISED TO GIVE YOU, AMERICA AN
ACCURATE NUMBER OF HOW MANY
AMERICANS ARE STILL TRAPPED, BUT
TODAY NO SUCH LUCK, DEPENDING ON
WHO YOU TALK TO AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AS MANY AS
4,000 AMERICANS ARE STILL TRYING
TO GET OUT OR ACCORDING TO
ANTONY BLINKEN, IT COULD BE
1500.
PLUS OR MINUS A FEW DOZEN HERE
OR THERE.
THEY STILL HAVE NO IDEA, NOT A
CLUE, THIS IS CRITICAL
INFORMATION, WE NEED AN ACCURATE
COUNT DESPERATELY, ANY AMERICAN
AFGHANISTAN AFTER
AUGUST THE 31ST, THAT IS THIS
COMING TUESDAY WILL BE LEFT
BEHIND ENEMY LINES AND
SUBJECTED, OR SUBJUGATED TO THE
WHIMS OF BRUTAL TERRORISTS,
OSTENSIBLY, YES, THEY WILL BE
HOSTAGES.
AND TODAY WHEN ONE NBC REPORTER
ASKED BIDEN WHAT HE WILL DO IF
AMERICANS ARE STILL IN
AFGHANISTAN AFTER THE TALIBAN
DEADLINE THAT HE SAID HE AGREED
TO, BIDEN RESPONDED WITH A JOKE.
HE WILL BE THE FIRST PERSON I
CALL?
YOU DECIDE IF IT'S FUNNY.
>> NOT PARTICULARLY FUNNY TO ME
CONSIDERING HOW DIRE THINGS HAVE
BEGUN.
THE PRESIDENT ASKED ANSWERED
ZERO QUESTIONS AS PER USUAL.
DOES NOT WANT TO GET IN TROUBLE
AFTER THAT AND SAID NOTHING
ABOUT THE CRISIS, NOT ONE WORD
IN AFGHANISTAN.
MORE IMPORTANT THINGS TO DO.
LIKE TOUTING THE $5 TRILLION IN
RECKLESS SPENDING INSTEAD OF
BEING FULLY FOCUSED ON FIXING
THIS MESS IN AFGHANISTAN THAT HE
HIMSELF CREATED.
BIDEN SECRETARY OF STATE
MEANWHILE NOTED THAT THERE WERE
NO CONCRETE PLANS FOR EVACUATING
PEOPLE AFTER AUGUST 31ST.
OTHER THAN CERTAIN DIPLOMATIC
EFFORTS AND ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE,
I WONDER IF WE CALL THAT RANSOM,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IS THERE ANY CONCRETE STEPS
YOU CAN GIVE TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
VERY WORRIED UNDERSTANDABLY
ABOUT WHETHER THEY ARE JUST
GOING TO BE FORGOTTEN, LEFT
BEHIND, DISAPPEARED, ONCE THE
UNITED STATES WITHDRAWS THE
MILITARY AND CAN NO LONGER
PROTECT THEIR SAFE PASSAGE TO
THE AIRPORT OR THEIR LIVELIHOOD?
>> THE SHORT ANSWER IS NO, THEY
WILL NOT BE FORGOTTEN.
AND AS I SAID, WE WILL USE EVERY
DIPLOMATIC, ECONOMIC, ASSISTANCE
TOOL AT OUR DISPOSAL.
WORKING HAND-IN-HAND WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
>> Sean: MILITARY WILL BE
GONE, SO WE HAVE DIPLOMATIC AND
ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE AS OUR TOOLS
TO USE TO GET AMERICA'S FREE IF
THEY ARE LEFT BEHIND.
IN OTHER WORDS THE GRAND MASTER
PLAN POST AUGUST 31ST, LET'S BEG
AND BRIBE THE TALIBAN, PAY A
RANSOM TO RELEASE ANYONE STILL
HELD HOSTAGE BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
WHICH IS PRETTY MUCH WHAT WE ARE
NOW DOING EXCEPT AFTER
AUGUST THE 31ST OUR MILITARY
WILL BE COMPLETELY EVACUATED.
THE AIRPORT WILL BE IN TOTAL
CONTROL OF THE TALIBAN AND
ANYONE LEFT BEHIND WILL HAVE NO
WAY OUT.
WHY?
BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN, OUR PEOPLE
AND FELLOW CITIZENS QUITE
LITERALLY WILL BE AT THE MERCY
OF TALIBAN TERRORISTS.
BIDEN IGNORED ONE WARNING AFTER
ANOTHER AS A COUNTRY LITERALLY
COLLAPSED BEFORE THE WORLD'S
EYES.
MULTIPLE SOURCES TELLING ME
TONIGHT THE CIA, THEY PULLED OUT
SIX OR SEVEN WEEKS AGO AND TO
THEIR CREDIT, THEY WERE TELLING
JOE BIDEN EXACTLY WHAT WAS
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND, THEY
DID NOT TO MINCE WORDS, AND BY
THE WAY, WE ARE TOLD OUR SOURCES
SO DID THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE.
JOE BIDEN COMPLETELY IGNORE THEM
IN THE WAY HE HAS BEEN
CHARACTERIZING IT TO YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, IS COMPLETELY
AT ODDS WITH THE INTELLIGENCE
THAT HE WAS BEING GIVEN.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
OF THOSE PAPERS WILL COME OUT
ONE DAY PRETTY IGNORE THE
WARNINGS, LOOK AT MAN
AFGHANISTAN WHEN THE TALIBAN
BEGAN THEIR OFFENSIVE.
HE IGNORED, NOTICE THE RED THAT
STARTS TO TAKE OVER.
THEN IN JUNE AFTER THE TALIBAN
TOOK CONTROL OF DOZENS OF
PROVIDENCES, WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE GREAT AFGHAN ARMY JOE BIDEN
WAS BRAGGING ABOUT?
HE IGNORED THE WARNINGS IN JULY,
LOOK AT THE MAP IN JULY WHEN THE
TALIBAN CONTROLLED THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE COUNTRY AND WERE
ON THE MARCH.
WE STILL HAD CONTROL OF THE
KABUL AND COULD HAVE SEEN WHAT
WAS HAPPENING AND ACTED
IMMEDIATELY.
AND WE COULD HAVE LOGISTICALLY
SAFELY EXTRACTED EVERY AMERICAN
AND OUR EQUIPMENT, THAT I WILL
GET TO IN A MINUTE.
IN FACT, JUST AS THE TALIBAN WAS
CLOSING IN, BIDEN CLOSED THE AIR
BASE, BY THE WAY, THE TRUMP PLAN
WOULD'VE KEPT THAT IN OUR
POSSESSION AND SO BY AUGUST IT
WAS TOO LATE, GAME OVER, NOR DID
HE WANT TO COME BACK FROM HIS
VACATION.
OUR EMBASSY WAS ABANDON ANY
STATE ON VACATION.
THOUSANDS OF ADDITIONAL AMERICAN
TROOPS HAD TO BE SENT BACK TO
KABUL EVEN THOUGH WE SAW THIS
ALL COMING, JUST TO SECURE THE
AIRPORT WHICH IS NOW HER ONLY
WAY OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
THERE IS ONE PROBLEM WITH THAT,
THE TALIBAN CONTROLS THE ENTIRE
PERIMETER OF THE AIRPORT WITH
ALL THEIR CHECKPOINTS AND THEY
ALONE DECIDE WHO WILL GET TO THE
AIRPORT, BUT ACCORDING TO
JOE BIDEN, THIS WAS ALWAYS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
THERE WAS NEVER A WAY OUT THAT
IT IS NOT CHAOTIC.
YES, THERE WAS.
HIS HANDS WERE TIED TO ANY PLAN
SCENARIO.
THAT SEEMS TO BE A LIE ALSO.
NOTHING CAN BE FURTHER FROM THE
TRUTH.
THIS ALL COULD'VE BEEN PREVENTED
EASILY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE MY WORDS
FOR IT, JUST LISTEN TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IS WAY BACK IN 2017.
HE RAN ON THE PLEDGE THAT HE
WANTED TO GET US OUT OF THERE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE CONSEQUENCES OF A RAPID
EXIT ARE BOTH PREDICTABLE AND
UNACCEPTABLE.
9/11, THE WORST TERRORIST ATTACK
IN OUR HISTORY WAS PLANNED AND
DIRECTED FROM AFGHANISTAN.
BECAUSE THAT COUNTRY WAS RULED
BY A GOVERNMENT THAT'S GAVE
COMFORT AND SHELTER TO
TERRORISTS.
A HASTY WITHDRAWAL WOULD CREATE
A VACUUM THE TERRORISTS
INCLUDING ISIS AND AL QAEDA
WOULD INSTANTLY FILL, JUST AS
HAPPENED BEFORE SEPTEMBER 11TH.
>> Sean: REMEMBER NOT A SINGLE
AMERICAN WAS KILLED IN THE LAST
18 MONTHS OF THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY, AROUND 18 MONTHS AND
THAT WAS AFTER YOU MADE THE DEAL
WITH THE TALIBAN AND GUESS WHAT
THEY WEREN'T ON THE MARCH AND
THEN BECAUSE THEY BELIEVED AND
FEARED DONALD TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS RIGHT IN
2017, JOE BIDEN WAS WRONG AND
NOW THANKS TO HIS HALF-BAKED
WITHDRAWAL PLAN, THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IT'S GUARANTEED AT THIS
POINT THAT THEY WILL SADLY DIED.
AFGHANS THAT ASSISTED US WILL
DIE AND AMERICANS EVERYWHERE ARE
LESS SAFE.
IN LESS THAN SIX DAYS ANYONE
LEFT IN AFGHANISTAN WHO ASSISTED
THE UNITED STATES OR THE AFGHAN
GOVERNMENT ALONG WITH THEIR
FAMILIES WILL BE KILLED BY THE
TALIBAN.
IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING ACCORDING
TO REPORTS.
AMERICA LEFT BEHIND THE ENTIRE
DATABASE NOW WITH THE TALIBAN
POSSESSION.
THEY WILL ALL BE HUNTED DOWN AND
WHEN THEY ARE CAUGHT, THEY WILL
BE MURDERED AND JOE BIDEN IS THE
PERSON YOU CAN BLAME.
AND THINK ABOUT THIS, MANY OF
THEM WILL BE MURDERED WITH THE
VERY WEAPONS THAT JOE BIDEN DID
AN END TO MAKE PREPARATIONS OR
DESTROY AT THE VERY LEAST, I
WOULD'VE BROUGHT THEM HOME.
A REPORTED $83 BILLION WORTH OF
WEAPONS THAT YOU PAID FOR.
THAT INCLUDES GET THIS, 75,000
ARMORED VEHICLES.
GET THIS, 208 BLACK HAWK
HELICOPTERS AND OTHER AIRCRAFT.
AT $200 MILLION WORTH OF DRONES
COULD WE GAVE THEM OUR DRONES,
600,000 MILITARY GRADE GUNS AND
OTHER WEAPONS, AND LET'S NOT
FORGET THE THOUSANDS OF
NIGHT VISION GOGGLES, UNIFORMS,
BULLET PROOF VESTS, OTHER
PROTECTIVE GEAR AND TO TOP IT
OFF THE TALIBAN EVEN HAS ACCESS
NOW TO BIOMETRIC DATA LEFT
BEHIND.
THAT MEANS FOR ANY AFGHAN OR
ANYONE THAT ASSISTED, U.S.
FORCES OVER THE PAST 20 YEARS,
THEY WILL BE TOLD LOOK INTO THIS
COMPUTER AND IF THERE IS A
MATCH, THAT PERSON WILL DIE.
AND TO TOP IT ALL OFF, AL QAEDA
IS VERY MUCH ALIVE AND WELL
DESPITE OF WHAT JOE BIDEN AND
OTHERS ARE SAYING IN AFGHANISTAN
AND THEY ARE WORKING
HAND-IN-HAND WITH THEIR BROTHERS
IN THE TALIBAN.
THEY WILL LIKELY HAVE ACCESS TO
SOME OF THESE WEAPONS AND NOW A
SAFE HAVEN TO PLAN FUTURE
ATTACKS LIKELY AGAINST US AS
THEIR NUMBER ONE TARGET.
THIS IS OUR INTEL CAPABILITIES
HAVE BEEN SHATTERED BUT CREDIT
TO CIA AND INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, THEY DID WARN
PRESIDENT BIDEN, THE CIA PULLED
BACK ACCORDING TO MY SOURCES AND
THEY WARNED IN GREAT DETAIL
EXACTLY WHAT WOULD HAPPEN.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THERE IS A
PAPER TRAIL.
NOW THERE WILL BE PEOPLE THAT
ARE LEFT THERE, WE WILL BE LESS
SAFE HERE AT HOME, JUST 20 YEARS
AFTER 9/11.
OPERATION ENDURING FREEDOM HAS
NOW UNDER JOE BIDEN BECOME
OPERATION TIERNEY AND DEATH.
JOE BIDEN DOES NOT SEEM TO BE
BOTHERED.
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS, FRIENDS
HOPELESSLY TRAPPED BEHIND ENEMY
LINES AND RIGHT NOW I GUE